WILL: SCHOOL IS BACK -- IT'S
BEEN BACK FOR A WHILE IN MOST
PARTS OF THE COUNTRY -- BUT THAT
ALSO MEANS YOU PROBABLY HAD A
CHANCE TO GO TO PARENT-TEACHER
NIGHT.
IT MIGHT BE TIME TO START
UNDERSTANDING WHAT YOUR CHILDREN
ARE LEARNING.
PETE: CORRECT.
MANY SCHOOLS ACROSS THE COUNTRY
ARE USING THEIR VISION OF
CURRICULUM ONTO YOUR KIDS.
AND WHILE SOME GO UNNOTICED,
OTHERS, ESPECIALLY ON THIS
PROGRAM, HAVE RECENTLY BEEN
EXPOSED.
WILL: SO LET'S GO OFF THE WALL
TO GIVE YOU A FEW EXAMPLES.
FIRST, PETE, TAKE US TO HISTORY
CLASS.
PETE: YEAH.
THIS IS BELLEVUE HIGH SCHOOL IN
WASHINGTON, THEIR S&P SON WAS A
JUNIOR AND WAS PLANNING TO TAKE
A U.S. HISTORY COURSE.
WHEN HE ACTUALLY TOOK THE
COURSE, IT WAS -- THIS IS THE
SYLLABUS, DECOLONIZING U.S.
HISTORY.
COMMUNITY AGREEMENTS YOU NEED TO
SPEAK YOUR TRUTH.
BE PREPARED TO EXPERIENCE
DISCOMFORT.
AND IF YOU LOOK AT IT, WILL,
FRONT AND CENTER, IS AND THERE'S
A LOT GLARING, WHAT IS
DECOLONIZING U.S. HISTORY, BUT
IT'S THE TEXTBOOK DOWN HERE ON
THE BOTTOM WRITTEN BY THIS GUY
THAT HAS A LOT OF PEOPLE RAISING
THEIR EYE EYEBROWS.
WILL: HOWARD ZIP, A RE-- ZINN, A
REWRITING OF AMERICAN HISTORY.
PETE: IT IS AN ANTI-AMERICAN
U.S. TEXTBOOK WHICH IN THIS
PLACE THEY PUT ON THE FLYER, BUT
IT'S OFTEN THE BAY ACCESS FOR
THE ACTUAL TEXTBOOK.
WILL: AND YOU SPOKE TO SOME
PARENTS ABOUT THIS EXACT ISSUE.
PETE: THAT'S RIGHT.
MICHELLE AND CAL.
LISTEN.
>> FIRST PARAGRAPH SAYS THAT
WE'RE GRATEFUL TO STAND ON THE
LANDS OF ONE INDIAN TRIBE, AND
WE ACKNOWLEDGE THE PRESENCE OF
IT.
SO IT'S, YOU KNOW, WHITE GUY
BAD, YOU STOLE THE LAND FROM THE
INDIANS.
>> IT'S EXHAUSTING TO BE A
PARENT RIGHT NOW AND TO HAVE TO
BABYSIT WHAT'S GOING ON IN THE
CLASSROOM.
I GUESS CALVIN AND I ARE ARE
GOING TO BE HISTORY TEACHERS.
PETE: BY THE WAY, THOSE PARENTS
PETITIONED THE SCHOOL FOR THEIR
KID TO BE ABLE TO CHANGE THE
U.S. HISTORY COURSE HE NEEDS TO
GRADUATE, THEY WOULDN'T LET HIM
OPT OUT OF THE COURSE.
YOU'RE IN OUR WORLD NOW, THE
SCHOOL SAYS.
WILL: ALL RIGHT.
NEXT, QR CODES IN THE CLASSROOM.
PETE: YES.
HILLIARD SCHOOL DISTRICT IN
OHIO, ULTIMATELY, PARENTS HAVE
SPOKEN OUT ABOUT THE FACT THAT
KIDS ARE BEING TOLD TO TALK
ABOUT GENDER TRANSITIONS OR
CONVERSATIONS OR CHANGING THEIR
PRONOUNS WITHOUT CONSULTING THE
PARENTS.
AND IN THIS PARTICULAR DISTRICT,
THEY POINT OUT THESE NEW BADGES
BEING HANDED OUT BY THE NATIONAL
EDUCATION ASSOCIATION.
PARENTS -- EXCUSE ME, TEACHERS
CAN WEAR THEM VOLUNTARILY, BUT
THEY SAY TO STUDENTSES SAFE
PERSON, SAFE SPACES.
AND IF YOU SCAN THE QR CODE, YOU
ARE BROUGHT TO SEXUALLY EXPLICIT
MATERIAL THAT YOU WOULD NOT WANT
YOUR KIDS SEEING, BUT IT'S RIGHT
THERE IN THE CLASSROOM.
WELL YOU HAD A GREAT INTERVIEW
WITH A TEACHER THAT SAID THEY'RE
TOLD YOU'RE NOT QUALIFIED TO
TALK TO STUDENTS ABOUT THEIR
DEPRESSION OR ANXIETY, BUT
TEACHERS ARE TALKING TO THEM
ABOUT THESE VERY SENSITIVE --
PETE: YES.
I WONDER WHAT DIRECTION YOUR KID
WILL BE TURNED WHEN A TEACHER IS
WEARING THIS BADGE AND THEY'RE
TOLD TO CONSULT ON, SAY, SEXUAL
ISSUES.
ONE OF THE PARENTS, OMAR, TALKED
ABOUT THESE GENDER CONVERSATIONS
INSIDE ONE OF HIS KIDS'
CLASSROOMS.
TAKE A LISTEN.
>> AND AT SCOOP THEY'RE
SAYING -- SCHOOL THEY'RE SAYING,
ON THE ONE HAND, WE CAN BE JUDGE
AND JURY, ESSENTIALLY, AS TO
WHETHER OR NOT IT'S IN THE
CHILD'S BEST INTEREST TO SHARE
THAT THE CHILD IS CHANGING
GENDERS AT SCHOOL.
BUT IN PRACTICE AND WHAT THEY'RE
ACTUALLY TEACHING AND TELLING
THE TEACHERS TO DO IS TO NOT
TELL THE PARENTS.
WILL: THERE YOU GO.
THE SUPERINTENDENT OF HILLIARD,
BY THE WAY, RESPONDED TO THE QR
CODE BACKLASH.
QR CODE IS NOT THERE TO BE
SHARED WITH STUDENTS; RATHER, IT
IS PROVIDED TO ADULTS BY THE NEA
SHOULD THEY BE INTERESTED?
LEARNING MORE ABOUT LGBTQ+
ISSUES.
PETE: I CAN'T SAY HALF THE WORDS
ON TV, WILL, THAT YOU WILL
ENCOUNTER IF YOU SCAN THAT QR
CODE.
IT'S PERVERTED.
THEY'RE HIDING IT FROM PARENTS,
AND TEACHERS ARE WEARING THAT
BADGE CREATED BY THE NATIONAL
EDUCATION ASSOCIATION.
WILL: NEXT, WE WANT TO INTRODUCE
YOU TO MARIO WHO'S SLAMMING
SCHOOL DISTRICTS OVER THIS
GENDER IDENTITY INSTRUCTION.
MARIO HAD THIS TO SAY RIGHT HERE
ABOUT ALL OF THIS INSTRUCTION.
>> IT HAS COME TO OUR INTENTION
THAT THE DISTRICT INTENDS TO
TEACH TRANSGENDERRISM URGE THE
AGE OF 10.
WHEN THE SCHOOL DISTRICT CAN
DOES IT, IT'S EDUCATION.
WILL: BY WAY, PETE, GAY MAN.
THIS IS OUTSIDE THE REALM OF
EDUCATION RIGHT NOW, BUT PAIR
PAL HAS PUSHED OFF -- PAYPAL HAS
PUSHED OFF FUNDS BEING RECEIVED
BY PEOPLE IN THE GROUP GAYS
AGAINST GROOMERS.
IF YOU ARE DONATING TO MATH
ORGANIZATION, PAYPAL'S COOL.
PETE: HE SAYS GROOM DOGS, NOT
KIDS, HE'S A DOG CAN GROOMER.
THIS IS A GAY MAN WILLING TO
SPEAK OUT ABOUT WHAT'S HAPPENING
IN OUR CLASSROOMS.
GENDER DYSPHORIA, AND, OF
COURSE, A LACK OF PARENTAL
CONSENT.
IN THIS CASE IT'S CALIFORNIA,
AND WE REACHED OUT TO CANEJO
VALLEY SCHOOL DISTRICT BUT DID
NOT HEAR BACK.
TEACHERS TALKING ABOUT INTIMATE
TOPICS OF SEXUALITY WITH OUR
YOUNGEST OF KIDS WITHOUT PARENTS
BEING CONSENTED.
AND IF YOU WERE TO STAND OUTSIDE
A WALMART AND TALK TO KIDS ABOUT
THOSE TOPICS, YOU'D GO AWAY IN
HANDCUFFS.
NOT INSIDE A SCHOOL.
THERE WE GO.
WE'VE WITHOUT A FOURTH ONE.
WE'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT
SEXUALITY.
HOW ABOUT MATH?
APPARENTLY, MATH YOU CAN BE
SYSTEMICALLY RACIST IN THAT AS
WELL.
WILL: ANTI-RACIST MATH.
JEFFERSON COUNTY PUBLIC SCHOOLS
HOSTED THE RACIAL EQUITY
INSTITUTE, AND THIS IS SOME OF
THE STUFF IT FOCUSED ON.
YES, WHITENESS THEORY, WHATEVER
THAT IS.
MODERN DAY RACISM.
EARLY CHILDHOOD LGBTQ+ STUDENTS
AND FAMILIES ACROSS THE BOARD,
AND WE JUST TOUCHED ON SOME OF
THAT, BUT IN JEFFERSON ALSO
THEY'RE TALKING ABOUT
ANTI-RACIST --
PETE: OH, MAN, IF YOU DO 5 TIMES
6 YOU GET DON'T BE RACIST.
WILL: WELL, TAKE THAT AND FILTER
IT THROUGH THIS.
PETE: YOU'RE RIGHT.
AND RUN IT THROUGH A COUPLE OF
THESE STRIPES --
WILL: MODERN DAY ALGEBRA, BABY.
PETE: YOU'RE RACIST.
THAT'S IT.
[LAUGHTER]
WILL: YOU THOUGHT ALGEBRA WAS
COMPLICATED --
[LAUGHTER]
THIS IS EVEN MORE COMPLICATED.
THAT'S WHAT'S, PERHAPS, TAKING
PLACE IN YOUR --
PE